Hi, I’m Derek Sarno.
I'm a vegan chef.
I specialize in bringing mushrooms
and veg to the center plate
by unleashing the mighty
flavors of plants.
I cofounded a plant-based food company
called Wicked Kitchen,
and I lead plant-based innovation
at one of the world's largest
grocery retailers.
In case you’re wondering
what plant-based and vegan means,
it's super simple.
Vegan and plant-based foods
are entirely free from animals
and from their byproducts.
Think no animals harmed nor killed.
No meat, no fish, no dairy milk
or eggs are used at all.
Just amazing plants.
Vegetarianism also
doesn't contain animals or fish,
but allows dairy and eggs,
the byproducts taken from animals.
Here are a couple of vegan things
that I've made recently.
A steak? No way.
Actually, there are no T-bones about this.
It's made of lion's mane mushrooms,
the barbecue butter sauce,
cast-iron seared,
one of the most nutritious
mushrooms on Earth
and known to be brain-boosting.
Pressed Greek-inspired
souvlaki steak sandwiches
with all the fixings?
This one is made with supersexy,
delicious brown oyster mushrooms.
Grilled pepper steak kebabs?
Great on the barbecue.
Packed with punchy flavors
and made with the super versatile
and delicious king oyster mushrooms.
Yes, all of these are plant-based,
and all of these are done
with a variety of mushrooms.
Why is this so important?
Meat eating is linked to climate change.
Eating animals and animal agriculture
is the leading cause
of rainforest deforestation.
Meat production is a significant source
of greenhouse gas emissions,
and there is a reason moms and doctors
tell us to eat more veg.
That's partly why I'm a vegan chef.
My other reason has to do with grief
and dealing with the unexpected death
of losing my partner.
The suffering and grief I felt
was suffocating.
I had two choices:
to go down a road of self-destruction
or accept what had happened
and find a way through it.
The loss of Amanda made me realize
my whole life to that point was based
on ego and attachment.
Being the best,
cooking anything and everything
without a second thought
as to the consequences of my actions.
As long as the food tasted great
and I was paid well for it,
I didn't care where it came from
or if it was animals
or the implications
and consequences that had.
Long story short,
I ended up laying my old self to rest.
Selling off the food business
and living in a Buddhist
monastery for three years,
where I learned to sit
and studied compassion
and how my mind worked.
What I discovered was a connection
to food and heart that I had ignored.
Animals suffer just as we do.
From then on, it became my mission
to find alternative ways
to prepare amazing food
that not only benefited people
but avoided animal suffering as well.
That time reflecting and learning
helped me reorientate my own moral compass
and opened up a whole new world
of creative cooking.
It also helped me become
much less of a jerk.
There are so many reasons
to eat plant-based,
and any reason that resonates with you
is the best reason.
I understand it's not always easy.
But eating even one plant-based meal a day
makes a huge difference.
I used to be a long time meat eater.
As a "regular" chef,
I used to cook lots of meat
and never made that connection
that they're living beings just like us,
with feelings, emotions and families.
I'm now on a mission to unleash
the mighty power of plants,
to create foods that we crave,
full of flavors and textures
that are more nutritious
and better for us and the planet.
I believe in compassionate action,
and the way I express that
is through cooking
and developing amazing recipes
that inspire and teach people
how to make and eat
delicious foods without animals.
Vegan food for meat eaters
and vegans alike,
because, like most people,
I want to save the animals and the planet,
but there's no way that's going to happen
if I have to compromise on taste.
Thank you.